le français stéphane peterhansel qui a
remporté le dakar en auto à son palmarès
impressionnant déjà vainqueurs six fois
en moto
il ajoute donc une nouvelle performance
dans une autre catégorie les meilleurs
moments à retenir de la course de
peterhansel julien bost mandaté légal
est historique
stéphane peterhansel et maintenant le
pilote le plus titré du dakar cette
victoire
retour sur la journée du 1er levé 7
heures peterhansel est plutôt détendue
premières sollicitations premières
impressions ça fait longtemps que
j'attends j'attendais ce moment il est
encore pas arrivé il est de plus en plus
proche donc
ça bouillonne un peu à l'intérieur c'est
sûr pas question d'en parler aux autres
pilotes
pas question non plus de leur livrer son
secret j'ai gagné six fois le dakar en
moto mais j'avais toujours le même pour
dana un bandana qui sert pour un motard
parce qu'on a au vent et tout et puis en
fait j'ai jamais réutilisé en voiture et
cette année à cette année je vais réagir
retrouver mon bandana de l'épaule de la
moto et tous les jours j'ai mis autour
du cou et et jeu et je vais le garder
jusqu'à l'arrivée c'est sûr plus que la
superstition c'est la régularité qui a
payé
à 38 ans stéphane peterhansel disposait
cette année d'une voiture fiable et
surtout beaucoup plus rapide que ses
concurrents
ajoutez à cela 15 dakar au compteur et
un copilote avec qui l'entente est
parfaite
résultat très peu d'erreurs de pilotage
encore moins d'orientation au final il a
presque une heure d'avancé sur le
deuxième il a tellement prouvé qu'ils
étaient forts d'entre eux utilisaient je
sais pas la prochaine fois peut-être
qu'il ira sur la lune avec une navette
spatiale dont papa vainqueur en auto
après six victoires en moto une de ces
journées qui compte dans la carrière de
stéphane peterhansel